kick us off ross because there is a lot
happening yeah lots going on anyone
obsessed with pop culture here hi
[Music]
okay well there is love in the air okay
new romance in bloom people reports that
olivia wilde
has been seen holding hands with harry
styles
turns out she's only looking in one
direction
they work together on a movie she was
directing called don't worry darling and
okay for starters uh this is the romance
i didn't know
that i needed to happen and i'm so into
it
how do you feel it's um you it's
undeniable they're both such incredibly
talented beautiful
inside and out alluring figures um
so i think i really understand why this
is
captivating everybody right now and it's
an antidote
to the realities that we're also going
through
so but also i just think about the baby
they have and like the jawline that baby
would have
and then also think about this i've done
the math so olivia wilde marries harry
styles and she hyphenates her name
olivia wilde styles i'm just saying i'm
done
you're welcome that works not only but
she's also like
a decade older and i'm really into that
because
i do think age is nothing but a number
and so
that's you know oh by the way i learned
a new word um
it's smexy which is messy and sexy
oh that's good fresh in from like the
younger generation
smexy sexy i've never been smexy once in
my life not even one time
hey would you date a guy that was like
10 years younger than you
um uh maybe i you know
you can't say no about who the other
person is
who you connect to to me doesn't have to
do with looks
status age it's something
more deep than that you know andy warhol
would say you
fall in love with your eyes closed and i
can only imagine what those nights were
like at the factory
um but i i concur
and for me you know even being on dating
apps i'm like gosh i just
i'm so much more interested in like the
inside of someone's
whole thing than the shell and that's
really all you get
but ross i'm back on the app oh you are
and guess what this is huge
i i'm telling you at 2020 was just such
a learning curve and prepared us all and
i said you know what
new year and i got on and
i'm getting hit up like a lot
i can't believe it and so you know
can i be your wingman in 2021 i need a
serious like wingman and i love to talk
about this and it makes it so much fun
and i'm just you know i think it's so
much again about not the way like people
look it's how you feel
i think no one was hitting me up because
i had like a geodome of like
fear anxiety and like just blubber of
yuck
exactly who wants to i hope that's not
your headline on your profile
no but right now i feel different and
therefore the energy is different
the output so you know it's not about
how it looks or
functions it's it's energy and attitude
and confidence and
spirit and all of that and just saying i
can't wait because
tables are turning 20 21 is the year
girl
it is the year well ross i'm really
excited
to uh in addition cap this news off with
someone
uh very special to you yeah this is a
connected story to you
and i just found it profoundly important
and interesting ross take us away well i
had to bring this story to tell you and
to tell everybody watching a couple
years ago i had the honor of meeting
some people who really blew me away
um i was very lucky growing up to have
like an amazing mother i know
the power of what that does for somebody
and
someone else i know has an amazing
mother i'd like you to meet sarah and
parker cunningham they're using their
non-profit
free mom hugs to educate and advocate
for the lgbtq plus community
and guess what they're here right now to
tell us all about it
hello sarah and parker hi guys
please tell us about the experience that
inspired the free mom hugs
well uh free mom hugs was inspired
by this young man here um our youngest
son parker
uh came out when he was 21 as a gay man
and he said mom i met someone and that's
when i faced the reality that my son is
gay
and i felt like i had to choose between
my faith or
parker and so when he came out of his
closet i went
into mine and it was a journey that took
us from the church to the pride parade
and um i went to a pride festival with a
homemade button
and that red free mom hugs and with
anyone who made eye contact with me
i would say can i offer you a free mom
hog or a high five
and the first hug that i got was for one
beautiful young woman who said it'd been
four years since she got a hug from her
mom
from that experience we started the
non-profit free mom hugs
and now we have chapters in every state
and we're doing what we can to empower
the world
to celebrate the lgbtqia plus community
through visibility
uh education and conversation and still
give bugs
another detail that really moved me is
that
uh speaking of the woman who hadn't had
a hug from her
own mom is that you've stood in for
people's weddings you have officiated
you show up for those who don't have the
fortune
of a family member who can show up for
them
due to whatever the circumstances is
that holds them back and i have such
deep admiration for what you do
and it isn't about what's taken away
it's about what's put in its place
and you are that in human form thank you
oh there can never be enough love in the
world thank you so much for what you're
doing for so many people thank you
and we would like to donate five
thousand dollars to free mom hugs to
help you keep your doing
amazing oh my gosh
thank you thank you and thank you ross
for bringing
your important organization to our
attention and if you go to our website
at thedrewberrymoreshow.com
all your information a link and every
way you can support we'll be right there
and we'll be right back
[Music]